Now that the X-Men movie rights are finally
back in Marvel's hands, MCU fans are running
wild with speculation as to which mutants
might show up in the franchise first.
From A-list icons to ambitious wildcards,
these are the X-Men who most deserve a place
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
2018's Black Panther was more than just a
huge money-maker for Marvel Studios.
Sure, it grossed a cool $1.3 billion at the
box office, but it also kicked the franchise
up a notch by introducing a genuinely compelling
villain, a thought-provoking premise, and
arguably the best MCU romance to date.
But while Lupita Nyong'o's and Chadwick Boseman
shared some undeniable chemistry as Nakia
and T'Challa, the King of Wakanda actually
married someone completely different in the
comics: Ororo Munroe, also known as Storm.
In comic lore, Ororo and T'Challa first met
as children, when she used her weather-manipulating
powers to save the young prince from a kidnapping
in Africa.
The two young lovers remained close through
the years, eventually marrying in 2006.
Although they eventually had their marriage
annulled after the events of the Avengers
vs. X-Men story-line in 2012, they still shared
a good six years of marital bliss.
With Black Panther 2 officially slated for
release on May 6, 2022, Marvel has the perfect
opportunity to introduce Storm while staying
true to the source material.
Back in February 2018, Comicbook.com asked
director Ryan Coogler about a potential Storm
sighting in a future sequel.
He replied:
"I don't know enough about that acquisition
to even talk about it [...] if it's something
that goes through, I can't think of better
hands for those characters to be in than Kevin
Feige."
With the rights finally in hand, a Storm may
indeed be brewing for Black Panther 2.
He may not have been part of the original
comics team, but these days it's hard to imagine
the X-Men without Wolverine.
Hugh Jackman played the iconic role for 17
years and nine movies before finally deciding
to hang up his claws after 2017's wildly successful
swan song, Logan.
And while Wolverine might be pivotal to the
X-Men universe, his first major comic book
appearance didn't have anything to do with
them.
Logan's first outing was in 1974's Incredible
Hulk #181, in which he first fought the Jade
Giant - yes, he appeared in the last panel
of the prior issue but we said “fought”
- so relax.
What could this mean for the MCU?
Obviously, you could make the argument that
it would be fitting to introduce Wolverine
in a future Hulk project, either on Disney+
or on the silver screen.
Given that Mark Ruffalo's Bruce Banner lived
through the events of Endgame, you'd have
to assume that Bruce will show up in the MCU
again, too, right?
So what better way to bring him back than
to have him square off against an ultra-powerful
threat like Wolverine?
Most MCU fans were pretty excited to hear
that Tom Hiddleston's Loki would be getting
his own streaming series on Disney+.
And given that Endgame's alternate-reality
version of Loki is still hellbent on world
domination, it sounds like the ambitious trickster
will be getting back to his villainous ways.
“Surprise.”
In the comics, Loki once captured one of the
original X-Men, Iceman, to try and use his
freezing powers to make his Frost Giants stronger.
Given that the MCU's Loki is also portrayed
as the heir to Jotunheim, the land of the
Frost Giants, it's possible that Hiddleston's
iteration of the character will try this ploy,
too.
Bobby Drake's Iceman, one of the founding
members of the X-Men, has seen his popularity
grow throughout the years, but that's not
just because of his incredible, ice-powered
abilities.
In 2015, he came out as gay, making him an
important figure for representation in comics
the kind of representation that's long overdue
in the MCU.
Of course, tying your hopes to the God of
Mischief is usually a fool's errand and only
time will tell what Loki has up his sleeve
for his own series.
Comic book fans might know that Carol Danvers
has a seriously twisted history with longtime
X-Men member Rogue, whose absorption powers
made her one of the X-Men's most formidable
members.
Their beef began when Rogue, while working
with Mystique and the Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants, drained Carol's powers and memories,
stealing her powers of flight and super-strength.
Although Carol eventually reclaimed her identity
and abilities, she and Rogue have remained
fierce rivals throughout the years.
Of course, the Fox version of Rogue never
got to do anything this cool, and that's because
Fox didn't have the rights to Carol Danvers
so they obviously couldn't give her that backstory
in the first place.
Now that Marvel has reclaimed their mutants,
however, it's entirely possible that fans
might finally get a comic-accurate version
of Rogue in the MCU.
And where better to debut her than in Captain
Marvel 2?
Poor Channing Tatum.
For years, the Magic Mike star has been vying
for a Gambit movie with himself in the titular
role.
Sadly, it's looking more and more like that
film is never going to happen.
But maybe there's another way Tatum can play
the role of the Ragin' Cajun.
One of the many streaming series on the upcoming
Disney+ roster is Hawkeye, a show focusing
on Jeremy Renner's archer Avenger.
Despite his involvement in the Avengers movies,
Renner's Clint Barton isn't really perceived
as an A-list MCU character.
As such, his series isn't quite as hotly-anticipated
as, say, Loki or WandaVision.
Perhaps a great way to inject some much needed
pizzazz into Hawkeye would be to give Channing
Tatum what he's always wanted: a chance to
play Gambit.
The two heroes have crossed paths in the comics,
so it's not an entirely unprecedented move.
They both have somewhat similar powers, too,
with Barton's bow precision being comparable
to Gambit's explosive card-throwing accuracy.
And whether you have them at odds or teaming
up, it does seem like a great way to lend
some hype to a show that could probably use
it.
One of the many lasting impacts of Endgame
is that Gamora, longtime member of the Guardians
of the Galaxy, is no longer the same character
fans have grown to love.
Her whole existence was thrown upside-down
due to the one-two punch of her sacrifice
for the Soul Stone at the hands of Thanos
and the repercussions of the Avengers' time
heist.
Now, the MCU is home to a Gamora who is alive
but who hasn't gone on the journey fans have
witnessed, with no memories of her time with
the Guardians or with Peter Quill.
But don't cry for Star Lord just yet because
there could be a new flame appearing in his
near future.
Enter Kitty Pryde, the spunky, wall-phasing
member of the X-Men.
In recent years, Pryde has developed a strong
bond with Peter Quill.
They first met when the X-Men and Guardians
teamed up on a space mission involving the
Shi'ar alien race.
After completing the mission, the two lovebirds
remained close, giving the term "long-distance
relationship" a whole new meaning.
Although Fox's X-Men movies did include the
Kitty Pryde character, you could argue that
her minor role in that universe didn't really
do her justice.
This is a character who has done some seriously
impressive things on the page, including traveling
through time and even killing Wolverine.
So here's hoping a more comic-accurate Pryde
makes her debut in the MCU sometime soon.
James Wan's Aquaman hit theaters in 2018,
dominating the worldwide box office with a
gross of a whopping $1.1 billion.
Now, for seemingly the first time in the past
ten years, Marvel is staring at an opportunity
to take a page from the DCEU's playbook and
try to capitalize on the musclebound fish-men
craze.
One of Marvel's first-ever characters was
Namor the Sub-Mariner [NAY-mor the SUB-mair-ihn-uhr],
King of Atlantis.
It's been more than 80 years since his on-page
debut, and although he has fought both for
and against the heroes of the Marvel Universe
during that time, he is widely considered
a good guy.
He became an official member of the Avengers
in 1985, but more recently, he joined the
Uncanny X-Men in their 2009 comic run.
Namor's affiliation with the X-Men has actually
earned him a powerful rival in the past ten
years: Wakanda's King T'Challa.
During the epic Avengers vs. X-Men comic event,
a Phoenix force-corrupted Namor even went
so far as to attack Wakanda with his Atlantean
army, bringing great destruction to the African
nation.
Should Marvel choose to bring their "first
mutant" into the MCU, Black Panther 2 could
be a great place to do so.
There was even a potential Easter egg in Avengers:
Endgame that fans believe hinted to his arrival,
with Okoye mentioning a sub-oceanic earthquake
off the coast of Africa.
"It was a mild subduction under the African
plate.
“Do we have a visual how are we handling
it?”
“Net.
It’s an earthquake under the ocean."
Fingers crossed for a clash of kings in T'Challa's
next solo outing.
When Jubilee joined the X-Men at the dawn
of the 1990's, she became one of the youngest
members of the team's roster.
A mutant capable of shooting firework-like
energy plasmoids out of her hands, the young
Chinese-American heroine quickly became a
fan favorite due to her quirky personality
and dazzling appeal.
However, after a run-in with a certain foe,
she became much more than just a mutant.
In the Curse of the Mutants crossover event
in 2011, the X-Men found themselves going
toe-to-toe with vampires.
Yeah, vampires.
Anyways, in the comics, Jubilee was bitten
by Xarus, the son of Dracula, and actually
became a vampire herself, making use of a
special amulet that allowed her to walk in
the sun.
Why should a vampiric mutant earn an early
invitation to the MCU?
Because the day-walker himself, Blade, is
coming soon to a theater near you.
If Feige and company add a fan-favorite like
Jubes to Oscar winner Mahershala Ali's MCU
debut, the hype will be unreal.
Talk about an explosive opening weekend.
Any mutant fan will know that Scarlet Witch
and Quicksilver are the biological children
of X-Men super villain Magneto, but you might
not know that the twins actually have a secret,
lesser known sibling: Lorna Dane, the green-haired
mutant also known as Polaris.
In the comics, Polaris shares similar abilities
to those of her father, being able to manipulate
magnetic fields and lift metals.
Although she has had her fair share of conflicts
with both heroes and villains, she eventually
joined the X-Men after they saved her from
the mutant-hunting Sentinels.
Although Emma Dumont already portrayed her
on FX's X-Men-affiliated series The Gifted,
there's no reason why the MCU couldn't adapt
their own version of the character.
Should Disney+'s WandaVision choose dive into
more of Wanda's origin story, discovering
a secretly gifted half-sister like Polaris
could make for a juicy plot twist.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.